hire an
epilogue, I know how, and Shishova, nothing
happened left, but firstly, I
heard where it’s terrible, terrible, such
as you, God is probably crazy by force, and
then I jump up, I don’t know where to
go, panic at first, of course, but I
ran out, so my windows go out and
selection and on  I ran out all the
cars of the siren, that is, all the
alarm cars were working, you know,
there’s no smoke, don’t say anything, what’s
happening is incomprehensible,
it’s five minutes for all of them, I had enough of you, the
victim, not to release that then I
open the doors already 50 literally passed the
police people stor born  with children in their arms
beauty
anal sick
horror something doom
where are you going now where are you going
to pick up children are we going to take the children out we need to take out the
cob there will be a link under love rub ode
tried it will be the
new Russian federation will not
stop just because they have made
no fraternal peoples we are not talking about
this  a stab in the back which we expected
because everything has been going towards this for a long time and
now we think that they would  they will make
every effort to destroy us and
our country, but we won’t let them do that,
so Putin Barristan,
for which
his own work and concept 2 total war and
for Yavin war and reich from life in
distant then service one know how to
sin only bad you you  you are
hitler in all holes in warm and robin
we want him to move to you and dance
rush and
ukrainian soup individuals but he often has fish as much as
you fries and you are for hold of america you are for
kharkov england
bam your have a warm floor
economic
how to recreate we  think will destroy
[applause]